un fiasco sin precedentes así describió
la prensa alemana el caos que ocurrió
aquí en Berlín durante sus elecciones de
septiembre de 2021 largas filas falta de
papeletas candidatos equivocados
horarios y regulares todo tipo de
problemas que llevaron a una decisión
judicial de anular esa elección y
ordenar la repetición que se realiza
precisamente este domingo aquí en Berlín
y de ahí que el enfoque esté no tanto en
los candidatos o en las propuestas que
presentan sino sobre todo en asegurar
que no se repitan los problemas del
pasado las autoridades locales han
puesto en marcha una serie de medidas
que incluye aumentar el número de
voluntarios durante el proceso electoral
y aumentar también el número de puestos
de votación para Berlín no solamente se
trata de elegir Quién será el próximo
alcalde o cómo estará conformado el
próximo gobierno local sino sobre todo
de asegurarse que la lección ocurra de
manera regular y transparente y que esto
pueda llevar a que mejore la imagen de
una ciudad particularmente afectada
después de las elecciones de 2021